bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors à moins de dix jours de
son procès pour extradition vers les
etats-unis racontez nous un peu comment
s'organisent les actions de soutien à
julian assange
alors je dois avouer que c'est très très
compliqué parce que tous les jours où on
a des restrictions supplémentaires
donc on a appris il y à peu près 15
jours qu'il y avait une 14 n imposait
alors on ne pourra pas s'y rendre
comme on avait l'habitude de le faire
puisqu'on février on s'était déplacé à
150 là bas avec les soutiens anglais des
soutiens européens aussi et donc là on
se dirigerait un rassemblement avec un
autre pays devant pendant ses parents
pour lequel parce que les frontières et
les restrictions viennent chaque jour
avec l'allemagne avec la belgique dont
donc là on est vraiment au jour le jour
on essaye de faire ce qu'on peut
en france on sait qu'on peut pas se
rassembler à plus de dix ans ça devient
très très compliqué pour soutenir
julian assange qui je le précise et
journalistes c'est pas un ancien dans
l'air c'est très important concernant
les actes d'accusation voilà c'est
vraiment un journaliste alors les
soutiens se multiplient comme vous
l'avez préciser tout à l'heure il ya
aussi julia nil qui a parlementaires
australiens avec une vingtaine d'autres
qui a fait un très bon discours il ya
quelques jours et qui appelle le haut
commissaire britannique à un rendez vous
urgent concernant ce procès qui est
scandaleux puisqu'il n'ya contact avec
ses avocats ne peut pas leur parler il
est dans un bon une boîte en verre
il essaie justement la compagne de
julian assange a déclaré qu'elle avait
trouvé fortement diminué physiquement
moralement lorsqu'elle lui a rendu
visite le 26 août à la prison de mails
belmarsh ce que vous êtes inquiète de la
dégradation de son état de santé à
l'autre d'un an de son procès oui tout à
fait parce que quand on sait que tu
viennes à une maladie
moner chronique dont il est déjà plus
sensible à tout ce qui est virale
il a une épaule qui devait extrêmement
souffrir il a aussi une entorse
donc on sait que enfermé 23h30 par jour
avec un seul ordinateur qui lui a été
remis très récemment dont les touches ne
fonctionne pas
il n'a que papier et stylo pour essayer
de prendre des notes qui n'a pas accès à
tous les documents pour se défendre
notamment à l'acte d'accusation qui a
été rajouté hors délai il faut bien le
préciser par là par les états unis
je crois que ça représente 800 mille
pages de documents très très dense donc
c'est vraiment à procès scandaleux
même les plus grands criminels de guerre
ne sont pas traités comme julian assange
qui je le rappelle est journaliste donc
c'est son métier
vous êtes d'accord avec l'association
robin des lois pour qui la zil politique
est la seule solution pour contrecarrer
la volonté de washington de le traduire
en justice
oui tout à fait toute façon il je ne
comprends même pas d'autres pays ne
demande pas aux etats-unis au
royaume-uni d'octroyer l'asile politique
qui avait été octroyé par l'équateur ne
l'oublions pas reims a été retiré par
par le second président lenin moreno mai
mais bon le doublé nasa avait obtenu cet
asile
il lui a été retiré d'une façon
scandaleuse également donc on voit que
tout est fait pour que ils arrivent à
leur fin et que julian finissent dans
une prison de très haute sécurité en
virginie où là les conditions en cessant
sont extrêmement dramatique et d'où
personne ne ressort donc on sait ce qui
va encore yves henry
depuis la nomination en france d'eric
dupond-moretti au poste de ministre de
la justice
un espoir rooney pour julian assange et
ses soutiens
on rappelle que l'actuelle garde des
sceaux était l'avocat du lanceur
d'alerté journalistes il ya encore
quelques mois
est ce que vous croyez vous qu'il peut
convaincre emmanuel macron de lui
accorder l'asile politique d'ici à son
procès une sorte d' annonce surprise
je pense tout à fait je pense que si la
volonté y est c'est tout à fait possible
et je pense que monsieur macro et cet
intérêt là aussi n'oublions pas que la
france est le pays des droits de l'homme
ça serait un petit peu redoré son blason
et ça ne serait que justice
j'espère qu'ils auront le rendez vous
puisque ce rendez vous a été demandé par
robin des lois il ya maintenant parce
que plus d'une semaine à ce jour on ne
sait pas si le rendez vous aura lieu ou
pas n'oublions pas que le procès le
procès et dans très peu de jours 1 7
septembre voilà ça nous laisse une bonne
semaine
alors on le rappelle julian assange
risque 175 ans de prison aux états unis
pour avoir divulgué des dossiers classés
secret défense sur les agissements de
l'armée américaine en irak et en
afghanistan comment vous expliquez que
sa situation ne suscite pas l'intérêt de
la communauté internationale et qu'il
soit complètement ignorés alors il est
tout à fait ignoré parce qu'on appelle
les médias meanstream 1 il faut il faut
vraiment remercier tous les médias comme
rt les médias indépendants qui font un
travail extraordinaire et qui essayait
de relayer l'information
mais pour être administratrice de ce
groupe je vois que la censure est
terrible notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux ouais on est bloqués
régulièrement le contenu ne correspond
pas au désir de facebook de twitter de
nombreux comptes sont bloqués on le voit
pour tous les journalistes qui est
arrivé à assistée par vidéo aux
différentes audiences d'administrative
qui ont eu lieu durant cet été il ya
vraiment
une mainmise par les états unis pour
bloquer toute communication et faire en
sorte que cette affaire là soit soit le
plus est tout à fait possible
on a vu comment il avait procédé avec la
sphère suédoise au début tout est fait
vraiment pour que les citoyens est une
mauvaise image de julian assange
n'oublions pas qu'il a toujours mérité
et il va toujours publier des vérités il
n'y a eu aucune faille
le travail est toujours approfondie
vérifier plusieurs fois avant d'être
publié donc c'est vraiment une source
d'information très sûr et qui ont plus
protège alors là pour le coup les
lançant valère corinne henry
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes activistes et
cofondatrice du collectif
assange ultime combat merci beau